[Musique]
vous vous faites car jaet ne vous
retournez pas ça va pas être
long attendez qui êtes-vous quelqu'un
qui préfère éviter de
s'impliquer tu as dit que les enquêteurs
des forces spéciales c'était ton équipe
ton groupe de soldats et même tes amis
des enentêteurs des forces spéciales il
font pasop les
chauffer et cette fois ils ont tous des
[Musique]
ennuis on les a torturé on l'a balancer
d'un hélicoptère il va chercher à s'en
prendre à nous tant
mieux les temps ont bien changé quand on
était petit on écrivait non non
là-dedans avz besoin de frapper si
fort je sais pas frapper
doucement quels sont les consignes
boss on se prépare on mène l'enquête on
envoie les méchants en prison tu vas
faire quoi
terminat ça me rappelle le bon vieux
temps ça ouais toi qui te planque à
l'écart pendant que je fais tout le
boulau GR de Chef Chef donne des
ordres ces types nous ont tiré dessus en
plein jour
[Musique]
sont il est doué pour sentir les choses
il est doué pour à peu près tout la vidé
surveillance ne fait pas honneur
à la nuit a été rude on dirait j'ai
Conn il faut uneutre veste qu'estce qui
va pas avec celleel il y a du sang
[Musique]
dessus